how much of the planets problems are
thanks to the white man most of my
problems are I gotta say that indigenous
rights have virtually been cut out of
the UN climate deal but indigenous
people from every continent have been
anything but absent here in Paris what
does it mean to you that perhaps the
final text of this new this deal won't
include the rights of indigenous people
it's so frustrating we're the first tend
to be the first communities to feel the
effects of climate change it affects our
way to it until it's a haunt together to
live off our traditional subsistence
lifestyles
we're also oftentimes at the point of
extraction whether it's mining or
fracking oils or coal companies are
coming in our deforestation efforts and
so it's a double whammy that we're
getting here when the rest of the world
doesn't have respect for indigenous
rights and the rest of the world doesn't
have respect for the rights of nature
and the laws of nature it's it's like
what can one person do what can one
country do because as long as it's it's
this kind of industry that the economy
is being built on and then it's crime
against nature you have to keep fossil
fuels in the ground you must put a
moratorium on fossil fuel development
that is the most sincere step that we
can take to address climate change
except for my loss of food finally what
is the has been the effects of the
fossil fuel industry where you live from
my community we have a coal company
Peabody Coal Mine they use billions of
gallons of water a year basically for
free and we've been through forced
relocations with our neighboring tribe
fighting over lands Landis views
welcomed diplomatic honest effect up a
todos heroes polling in business Denver
Mensa decir nosotros estamos cuidado
respeto yo mensaje tambien para que la
serda near-universal
k2v eran el mismo principio origin
original que nosotros Volvo recupera se
pensamiento kilo and perdido SS a
connection in spite of the challenges
groups like the indigenous environmental
network remain hopeful what we're doing
this mobilization this the social
movements that you've seen across
America this climate justice movement is
winning and it's working you just got to
keep on pushing